Attorneys general from 48 states, Puerto
Rico, and DC recently announced that
they're investigating Google for
possible antitrust violations.
The AG's want a say in how Google
manages advertising, uses AI, and displays
search results. Let's see: Attorneys with
political aspirations want to control
business strategy for one of the world's
most complex tech companies. what could
go wrong?
Plenty! Microsoft tried for years and
hasn't achieved Google's quality. And if
the AG's take Google down a few notches,
the cost to you will be three hundred
and eighty billion dollars annually in
lost search quality. And the
investigation doesn't look genuine. The
AG's have already said that Google is an
"existential threat", a "juggernaut", and that
it takes away people's freedom. Who
benefits from the investigation? EU
leaders: They've been trying for years to
hamstring US companies. And China's
leaders: Their tech companies are in hot
pursuit of the US. Let's hope the AG's
google "overconfidence" and realize they
can't improve tech services.
What do you think about the AG's investigation?
Should they proceed? Or should they drop
it? Let us know in our poll, and let us
know other topics that you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds, and be
sure to like and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI.